you know how sometimes things line up
coincidences since we've been up here
they've been happening more and more
it's like there's this black cloud
hanging over us what conversation do you
want people to have after seeing this
well I want people to you know first of
all I just want people to have any
conversation that that to me is the is
the goal if they wanted to start in
place I would say what is your part and
the evils that you observe you know in
order for us to to live a life in safety
or relative safety you know someone has
to live a life of danger we're connected
to evil whether or not we we face if on
a daily basis or not so maybe maybe we
are our own worst enemy right and I
remember I was like watching a lot of
your interviews and you were saying
there are a lot of messages in this
movie and this is so that movie that
after you're just like kind of
marinating like just thinking about all
the messages is there another one that
maybe you haven't touched upon yet that
you'd like like to open up about that
maybe isn't so obvious in the movie well
you know this movies about trauma and
generational trauma and this idea that
what happens in our ancestry or what
happens in generation before us affects
us and so it trickles down the main
character in this film has has a trauma
experiences of trauma as a child and
this is a story about that coming back
to haunt her and the trauma in this case
has its own family to bring things about
how it affects what happens to us and
what we buried deep and try not to face
affects the world that we make around us
I was just gonna say that like we bury
so deep in sometimes we just don't want
to face and some people never face it um
one of the messages obviously the
obvious one is self-examination is there
a part of yourself that's difficult for
you to face yeah absolute
yeah look you know I think I think it's
similar to you know what I didn't the
observation I'm making of us as a group
I have a I have a lived a life of
privilege
you know comparatively I'm you know I
wasn't born rich but I was born
comfortable middle class I had shoes I
had you know I had doctor I had
education at my disposal and not
everyone does and you take that for
granted it's so easy to they ignore
[Music]
people who are suffering it's so true
because you're just like oh well I feel
so bad but I'm not dealing with it it's
not my fault yeah it's easier to turn
the other way that's so interesting
um I'm such a big fan of yours and you
know after get out and watching this
movie I started thinking to myself when
I left yesterday will you ever make a
cameo in one of your own films I I've
made cameos in both of my films you have
huh and get out I was the voice of the
deer and in us I am a dying rabbit wait
does anyone know that no oh my god am I
the first person you told yes and yes
you are
Jordan that's crazy Oh see
congratulations thank you thank you now
if your life was a movie what would the
title of the movie be if my life was a
movie yeah
what was the title of it me it would
probably be the dreamer the dreamer
you know three times at the lifts of it
I don't know I you know yeah let's let's
let's just say it would be the dreamer
the Jordan Peele story oh that's - does
that's awful okay I'll think about
you